oh hi i'm here to show you guys today
the new nintendo DS okay first of all
that's my line second of all that's my
ids and we'll give it back to me the
nintendo dsi everybody wow so this a
whole lot like a DS lite it looks
exactly like a d/s light and that's uh
that's why it's it's it's kind of cool
but uh you're telling me before color
it's got some stuff in it this it's got
all kinds of crazy yeah all kinds of
girl looks can be deceiving okay so
first of all from the regular des it
looks like it's got this kind of like a
matte finish on there there's got a
matte finish on there so it doesn't have
that glossy finish and gets all your
fingerprints and smudges on it which I
really didn't like about the dslite yeah
also I'm looking at this all right so
there's got this thing right here that
we fighting right here I suspect that's
a camera one this thing right here is a
camera lenses are back let me blow your
mind not only does it have one camera
lens there it's got another camera lens
right there in the hinge just like a
macbook or whatever so you can take a
picture of yourself you can take a
picture of other people without turning
the d/s around and using the screen as a
viewfinder and then you can take the
pictures and there's an application
unless you play with them and and then
you can actually save the pictures if
you want you can use the pictures in dsi
software with that little bit later you
also save them to an SD card things got
it Hardison LC Karla yeah no way the
oldies to not have an SD the old es did
not have an SD card okay cool so obvious
did have a gameboy advance slot but you
play your old gameboy again now and just
does not there's nothing down there so
uh do you buy dsi you're not gonna play
your old gameboy games anymore but
really terribly really been playing your
old King boy Oh a little bit oh no not
really well save wanna save your es
lights are use that as your gameboy dsi
is all about the future you know what
the future is Danny ah wireless internet
that's just flying around the air yeah
all right digital distribution of video
games no more this going to store and
buying a game no no media is dying dsi
software if you're just going to
download it and you're actually going to
download it actually right from the dsi
just like how the wii has a wiiware shop
dsiware shop ok so there's it so there's
a
actual shop I can go to on the internet
on the inner tubes okay I stands for
Indian or tube and then i can download
any game i want from there or what's
what's the deal the deal well what
they're going to be doing right now you
can download a web browser and so you
can use the dsi to house the one so is
it is it a web browser nintendo mater's
it's a web browser actually by opera
it's very much a fee like you we browser
it actually uses both screens you can um
you know zoom in on on the webinar the
screen and see the full picture on the
other screen how can i get over to just
connect to the deus any web page pull
any web page you you want I'm gonna go
look at dirty web pages nice i'm not
really i don't think nintendo want you
to do that with their bro I'm not no no
but really the important thing here is
dsiware in December they're going to
release a new warioware game let's just
for the dsi it's gonna actually use the
camera so your it's gonna use your
silhouette to UM to actually project at
the avatar yeah yeah you'll see your
silhouette on screen you use them to
play the mini games that's um and also
you know they're just gonna do you know
a whole bunch of other um like actually
mini games from the game boy version of
warioware gonna be playable just in the
dsi you can buy them from a couple of
bucks okay yeah and so that's that's
really the so the Nomos idea sorry I got
another it's got a music player it's
gonna okay you know the photo app but uh
really it's about downloading games what
it's about downloading games taking
pictures of people yep or you know take
push yourself and then creating avatars
out of that ha alright here's a question
uh-huh why can't I read anything on this
o.o a Japanese that's what really
interesting on perceptive question Danny
you can't read any of it because as you
said it's all in Japanese it is all size
is available in Japan right now for
about one hundred and eighty five
dollars but not yet in the US and it
won't be out here till probably late two
thousand nine uh why do you think that
well because Nintendo is making so much
gosh-darned money off the nintendo DS
lite that they see no reason to
introduce this in the US just yet yeah
yeah so if you want it can you get on
like on amazon or ebay you go to a sites
that typically sell import video game
hardware like play asia calm and buy it
but you have to realize that the
downloaded software are going to be
region locked and so you may have it you
may have trouble um you know using
american credit card to buy software we
don't know that yet because the the dsi
we're barely you gonna leave this god
awful you literally just got off a plane
from japan with that like smuggles
somewhere else and i don't know where my
body we're not gonna say where yeah yeah
no i just had somebody sent to me but um
oh man that's not quite as interest no
isn't it's not butter nope but yeah
antenna dsi all right here and soon
chris kohler himself will I review me it
will be up on review wired.com / reviews
yep and he will rate it on a one to ten
scale and give it a definitive
definitive hate scoring things
it's hard it's tough hmm but you can do
it I know